greetings and salutations uh we recently
heard that the high yield or junk bond
market uh in the united states had
passed the three trillion dollar
mark uh certainly a massive milestone i
i couldn't be any more pleased today
that we're joined by dr kamal sri kumar
he's president of sri kumar global
strategies
but he is something of a legend in
in the world of high-yield
investing and i think he's going to be
able to walk us through a journey today
uh thank you so much for being being
with me very good to be with you
danielle and thank you for inviting me
to this interview
so uh start off with a little bit of
your background
your accent is definitely not california
where we are today in santa monica
the only thing i would say to you is i'm
doing a cross-country trip with my son
and stopping in rapid city south dakota
where i went over to a starbucks shop
and they looked at me and said are you
from california
and you would say what in my accent made
you think that
but it was my wearing a mask not my
accent so people say that for different
reasons but to go back to your question
no i was born in india
and came to colombia university as a phd
student
those were days of foreign exchange
controls imposed on the indian side
so the central bank gives you eight
dollars worth of foreign exchange at the
at the tax official exchange rate
you show up in new york wait for
colombia to give you your fellowship
money waive your tuition
to get a but the good ending was that
four years later i had my phd
and my mentor robert mundell who sadly
passed away earlier this year
was again a great inspiration in terms
of helping the finish the phd thesis it
was good and then after i've been in
this country
well i didn't know we had columbia in in
common but uh but that was certainly
a special time in my life i was actually
at columbia on 9 11.
coming up on the 20 20 year anniversary
different school getting my second
masters in in journalism
because i always wanted to write when i
left wall street and and here i am
writing and still involved with the
markets so
you were in a productive a rich school
we like to call it we were in the poor
school we were in a building called fair
weather
if you may remember we didn't even have
a coffee machine of our own we had to go
to the business school cafeteria to get
coffee
but despite that colombia was a lot of
fun a few years of being there
so where did you start
i started out in citibank which was my
first job for a lot of people it was
this place it was almost like a
continuation of school
and in the 1970s international lending
was expanding it was big and people and
water riston the legendary ceo of
citibank
used to say that countries do not
default ever
and so we all believed in that mantra we
went in with it
and but you had to assess the risk
involved in different countries
and that's how with my macro background
compared with international finance and
adding to it i became a country risk
analyst
and this went on for a few years i
worked at marine midland bank which
doesn't exist anymore marine midland i
haven't heard that in some ways yeah
it's been a while right maybe we will
because the new governor of new york is
from is from buffalo new york and that's
where marine midland was headquartered
it was purchased by hong kong shanghai
banking corporation
i became then believe it or not with my
accent and my look i became a specialist
on latin american countries
and when i began in 1979 i didn't know
the difference between argentina and
mexico i roughly knew where they were
but i was told by my boss we will have a
teacher come and teach you free and
teach you spanish
and that was the attraction six months
later i was in montevideo uruguay having
a discussion with the central bank on
their monetary policy in spanish
that's fabulous hablo espanol oh okay
i was just
i'm not sure how the rest of the
audience would feel about that i was
prior to covid my most recent trip uh
prior prior to cove it was with the with
with the central bank of mexico oh
one wonderful
the better managed central banks in the
region yes and cardenas has gone on to
uh to to continue to do good work
he's at the bis now
so
take us to latin america take us to that
to that time and and also
when you switched over from city to
another firm on another coast right city
and i talked to you about marine midland
and then
this is now we are going back to 1982
august of this year that year the
mexican officials were coming to the
federal reserve bank of new york to say
we are bankrupt we can't make any debt
payments anymore
and marine midland the way countries
don't go bankrupt yeah they don't go
bankrupt right
i think 140 broadway where we were
you can look diagonally across at the
federal reserve bank of new york
entrance and you saw this whole team a
cars part
and mexican officials whom you recognize
by sight they're all going into the
building wow you knew something was so
if you did a one of those peter lynch
type
shoe leather research you would know
something is dreadfully right
so
wait what did you say 140 broadway 140
broadway that's where i first
interviewed a dlj
oh my god you have a lot in common with
that as well as the columbia background
yes okay remember that with the bull the
raging boom that's right that's right so
it's looking at that and six months
later it became clear to me this is what
an economist does in long-term
forecasting i said this is not one of
the short-term issues you're facing this
is going to be a long-term problem
and i said i'm becoming a consultant
and he looked at me and said only people
who are fired become consultants
[Laughter]
it shows you how the world has changed
you don't need to become a consultant
and so think about it for two weeks and
come back
so i went um
just spent five days
and i said i don't need two weeks i've
spent five days i'm becoming consultant
zero client base
but what helped was the auditing firm
which was auditing marine midland i went
to them and appealed to them and said
look
you are auditing different money center
banks there then there was also other
banks like jp morgan chemical bank
manufacturers hanover
and even though you do that you don't
have an assessment of the countries and
how much the assets are worth i'm not an
accountant or a financial person but i
can give you the macro background to it
and you can use that essentially to show
the regulators you're taking adequate
care in assessing
your clients portfolios right this is
this is your due diligence your risk
assessment and it clicked and they
became my first client started with zero
within about two months i had that
and then thereafter another auditing
firm which uh audited the rest of the
new york city bank they found out well
they are hiring you as a consultant we
don't want to be left out without it i
got hired again there was no conflict of
interest i'm giving you country
information
so i could do both
and then soon enough i was audited i was
working for three of the then big eight
accounting firms
that got me started
then i had a few regional banks who
became clients so in the first year my
total intake revenue was just five
thousand dollars but in the second year
i was making more money than my bank job
and it was very enjoyable
and drexel burnham had just started a
debt trading group out of beverly hills
and the person who was there wanted help
in also getting advice on what what to
do about it
so i started and after the first meeting
the second time said can we meet a few
minutes before our meeting begins said
sure we met and he said how about
closing up your shop and coming and
meeting a person called michael milken
and i said oh i've heard his name i've
seen his name in newspapers
and so they said get on a flight and
come and the rest of it is history 1986
onward i've been on the west coast
and had a wonderful time at drexel
burner
those were the times when our ceo at
that time fred joseph used to say the
assets you're looking at
is you're not looking at junk you're
looking at toxic waste when you're
looking at latin america
and what we found was there were gems
among them
mispriced
assets
and it was a highly imperfect market
there was no bloomberg terminal to tell
you what it is worth or to make a one
basis point different
so trading meant you made a huge
difference between buy and sell
and i have interesting incidents one of
those was visiting rio de janeiro in
walking with a banker along the
copacabana and the guy says sri you know
we heard that brazil may reduce interest
payments next week i had not heard it
nobody had heard it
and it was common used in within rio in
the banking circles
so i went back to my hotel room urgently
called beverly hills and said this is
what it is
and the next thing we were shorting uh
brazilian debt and it was it turned out
to be a victory within the next couple
of weeks
so it was a very nice going and i think
mike with all his wisdom decided
that this was a time when you could
collect together all of those assets and
essentially get the people who are used
to high-yield investing
who understand risk
now you're not going to the mom and pops
of the world to buy them but you're
going to the sophisticated institutions
how they could come in
and the whole refinancing could be done
they would get an enormous profit if the
guess is correct because you're buying
at a deep discount right the countries
would get new financing which they are
not able to get from the banking system
the international monetary fund is not
providing it
and so started a fund it was actually
fun
in 1987 mike would talk to his clients i
would sit there giving the economic
story again i have no illusion that the
investors came in because of my wisdom
but it was good to be doing the pairing
with him so that he talks about the
countries and then i can explain what
the economic background was
started 170 million dollar fund which
was huge during those years right my
gosh 1987. yes yes and then uh it grew
and uh 1990 after drexel closed its
doors
uh tcw purchased that fund
and so and that fund with a different
name and a change in size is still in
existence
so many years later you're talking about
so many years later that continues to
exist
tcw then
hired me initially because of my latin
american
expertise
then it became looking at all of uh
emerging markets including asia
and mid 1990s i started to chair the
asset allocation committee globally
and it was a lot of fun we had a good
work there we looked at it top down on
the allocation side we didn't do
anything bottom up ourselves
we had portfolio managers who come and
tell us what they are doing in different
tcw strategies
and then from a top-down viewpoint you
decide whom you want to allocate how
much money to do you like this manager
what he or she is saying does it make
sense
and you allocate it and you are judged
by your investors
in terms of how much you exceed
your benchmark your your performance
and when i left tcw in 2012 the last
quarter wall street journal
rated 365
conservatively managed asset allocation
funds
we were called the king of those 365 so
that was very nice as a going away
present so it's been fun so when when
you say you were assessing
countries
you mean the world
all countries
it is only some countries which are
commercially important in terms of
lending and you're looking at two
areas danielle one is you're looking for
banks which have lent money and
therefore they were trying to see if
they would continue to be serviced
they will pay their interest and
principal payments that's one area of
interest
that's how it started because there was
no long-term equity investment
in those countries
they were not friendly in that area at
all when you're talking about the 1980s
and even into the 1990s
it changed
because this is what drexel was taking
advantage of
was debt to equity conversions that you
could do selectively in countries
that introduced the concept of equity to
foreign investors
but they were going in on a discounted
debt basis in order to gain entry
with the passage of time country risk
analysis took on a different tone what i
had to do was to say
what are the top-down characteristics a
country should have to attract foreign
direct investment
if you are following those qualities
which i want you to follow
that means i the risk of that country
going downhill is limited what would
they be
i want good economic management
economic growth should be steady and
positive because economic growth in turn
is a demand for more resources
and as bob mundell would say if you do
not provide that cash domestically
it has to come from abroad importing
cash means
running a surplus on your trade balance
or getting capital inflows coming so
that's the second quality that you want
to see
you want to look at the current account
deficit in the balance of payments
we want to make sure then
that the for fdi or foreign direct
investments are a good proportion of the
current account deficit for example a
good country
would be brazil
where fdi
has been 100
or more of the current account deficit
in a number of years
so why is that important
you say if you're following all of the
right policies and foreign direct
investments are substantial
they cannot turn tail and go away in the
next six months they are stuck for the
next five years
if they are stuck for five years they do
want long-term forecasts on how it's
going to be
that's the difference again not only
between brazil and turkey which depended
a lot on short-term capital flows
but also a difference between brazil and
argentina
you have to make a distinction the two
stock markets are highly correlated
but then you say
brazil is better managed
compared with argentina over the years
so if i have a hundred dollars to put in
i'm going to put most of it in brazil
and very little in argentina that's what
i said to a client with long-term
interest turned out to be a very good
brazil continued to prosper and the
small loan to argentina had to be
written down to zero
so that part so in terms of what the
country risk analysis does we are
looking at brazil was important mexico
argentina colombia chile again very
important as well
then in you go to moss russia
irrespective of the politics the russian
central bank i call it the university of
chicago classroom
um uh elvira nebulina the president of
the central bank
she manages interest rates like she
couldn't care less there is no political
influence involved in doing it
so if you do that you like a country
for foreign direct investment so
brazil is important russia is important
on the asian side china of course is
huge giant in terms of attraction well
but you were you were analyzing you were
probably there
kind of at the advent of the china that
we know that entered the world the world
trade organization in 2001 it was
presumably a much different market
prior to
its
evolution
to become what it is that we think of it
as today
when when did you first start kind of
assessing china
started assessing china in the mid 1990s
as you are absolutely right the opening
up took place in 1979
with them xiao pink
so let's say you've had 15 16 years of
opening take place by the mid 90s
but then when you go
to investors to look for money they were
still quite skeptical that china can
amount to anything at all
uh property rights were not well
established so you had to depend on
economic variables and the management
skill
to see whether you would get paid or
your foreign direct investment would pay
off
i remember going to one large investor
and we spent two hours making a
presentation a group of us
top down bottom up what we are trying to
say
and so when we in the middle of it after
about an hour
when two of us left for a rest break we
go out and we say
we are going to get a lot of money with
this investor
and two hours passed by and one of one
person then says uh how much do you
think you're going to invest
and the answer is
impressed oh i'm not going to invest
anything
i'm here to see who would be so crazy as
to go and make an investment in china
yeah that was the approach in the mid
90s
so we have come a long way
and after 1995
after 2000 especially after the world
trade
organization in 1901 that you mentioned
china became the darling of foreign
investors
but now i think once again
you're at a critical juncture
and country risk becomes very important
let me see may i explore please please
this is a very very hot topic right now
here are the reasons
you do not have country risk the way i
started to study in 1980 they are not
running short of foreign exchange
normally when you look at argentina or
brazil and there is a problem the
exchange rate goes kaput they just
depreciate like crazy not happening and
you read about these countries that are
running low on their foreign reserves
right these thin cushions and how
dangerous it could be yes that is not
happening or you find that in the case
of mexico in 1981 the foreign exchange
reserves were close to zero i went to
the
deputy head of the central bank and said
in spanish very
nicely how much reserves do you have
this is something the imf used to put
out of course and the answer i get is
no puedo
so you don't have the problem with china
today the foreign exchange reserves are
huge and they are a creditor to the
whole world then where does the risk
come from
you have to modify your thinking the
risk comes from the fact the communist
party is supreme
and you cannot cross swords with them
and you've had companies which have had
a difficulty in the stock market
because they did do something to show
that their company was more important
than the country or the communist party
we learned that's a no-no
so why does the country risk increase
because there are some companies that
you think are very good but it is not
going to work out if they run afoul of
the senior man senior management of the
country that is one issue
we think of jack ma and alibaba
both happened not only that but i was
astounded
the tutoring companies
they came down and the reason for that
daniel
was the fact that if you are dealing
with tutoring and if you run a tutoring
company
only i can afford to send my child to
your tutoring school the others cannot
so my child gets into a better
university other children do not and the
class distinction gets wider
and the communist party is threatened
and they use the united states by the
way is the example
that we don't want to go down that path
of income inequality so haves and they
have not yeah so that is the big issue
so as a foreign investor you are led to
speculate on what is it that you can
allow
where should you be investing and where
should you keep out of
tutoring company you would never have
expected would be something they would
come down on you might have anticipated
for alibaba what would you have
anticipated for the tutoring company
they said the tutoring company should
become non-profit and of course the
founders said i'm not going to run it as
a non-profit they gave up so that's one
element of risk sorry sure no no
continue
that is one element of risk the second
is and this is something i've been
talking to my clients repeatedly
and it looked like a sleeper issue the
china debt side
when you you look at the amount of
corporate debt and state and local
company government debt
the total my money my
quick estimate it's about 360 percent of
gdp when you add all the
unregulated debt
not the sovereign it is not a problem at
the central bank level which has a lot
of reserves right but the question is is
the central bank going to spend all the
reserves bailing out all of these people
probably not
so if you're buying chinese debt and
there are two companies right now which
are in the forefront one is called
evergrand which is a large property
developer right the other is a
distressed debt investing manager called
huarang
and both of them had have had a lot of
issues
and the government has essentially said
i want you to swim or sink by yourself
the question foreign investors have to
face is
is that another lehman brothers type
issue left in the future what does that
mean even brothers were supposed to be a
small investment bank inconsequential
and if we don't bail them out it won't
have any global consequences
we found it was wrong of course and the
question is how much do they bail out
and which companies do they not bail out
and if you make a mistake there
then uh it is going to have a huge
impact not only on china but on the
global markets so there's a second risk
it was interesting to see a few days ago
that the government put out a public
directive to evergrant to clean up your
act right
i'm i'm saying to myself with what yeah
how are they supposed to do this and yet
the government was public in in saying
you know you've got to write your debt
problems precisely they cancelled the
special dividend which everybody had
expected
that in turn caused the rating agencies
to take notice many of them have
downgraded
so that though those issues are not
going to go away they are going to stay
behind 2020 worsened the debt problem
because they had to increase credit in
order to get the economic growth going
very quickly right and china's story by
the way if we come to it later it should
be a lesson for the united states it
doesn't affect you when you're going
through the expansion process
it will hit you a year two three years
after you have done that so that i think
is a is a major issue third and final
one is really panoramic
the deteriorating u.s china relationship
and i like to say to my clients
when donald trump was president the
chinese could get away saying well he's
all alone he's attacking us in public
nobody is going to go with him and we
are okay we'll deal with the bombast and
nothing much will come out of it
what has happened now is you have a more
serene person who deals in diplomatic
talks
but yet the relationship has worsened
and none of the restrictions on the
chinese has been removed
and again china is not happy with the
situation they are planning to threaten
to retaliate particularly the fact that
chinese companies which are listed in
new york have to go through extra
regulation
then they'll have to disclose who the
real investors are it is this is just a
minefield that is coming up so those are
my three issues yeah you know it feels
like you know if you look back at at
history
you know what what can sometimes start
off as a trade war
there's currency wars there's trade wars
and eventually if the tensions rise
enough you start to talk about other
forms of war precisely and i don't know
that there's
i i think from from an investor's
perspective from an outlook or you know
from somebody looking from the outside
in we tend to separate away the
political from the economic and i i
think that that's potentially
problematic absolutely right you're spot
on you cannot separate the two you have
to look at them together
and whether the political is more
important or the economics is more
important can change with time
and you need to be going with the flow
in making those changes
and i think that is that's where i think
china is today
and i like to say to investors today
that you cannot go in just on a
bottom-up basis you can't say i have a
good company i've evaluated the earnings
and the management i'm comfortable with
it i'm going to buy that company you
have to say will that company run a foul
of the manage of the economic leadership
in beijing and what will that do to the
stock price
because as we have seen
when the uh when beijing comes down on
you the stock price just collapses right
as we saw with the tutoring company it's
black and white there's no there's no
gray there's no there's no there's no
cushion at all
um
let's shift gears since you mentioned
that there are ramifications
and even in the united states we've seen
not just a tremendous run-up of the
fiscal deficit and and u.s debt is
approaching 30 trillion dollars we've
seen corporations continue
uh to raise until record record levels
of day every every month they say oh you
know this is a record september we're
expecting uh for for debt issuance
at some point
do the two become also linked in the
united states because we don't think
about it that way
if somebody was to say
you know a state-operated enterprise in
china you could possibly conflate that
debt with sovereign debt but you would
never think that of the united states
that's an excellent point you should
conflate the two you should be looking
at them together in the united states as
well
because alongside the increase in the
fiscal deficit and the federal debt that
you spoke about
the companies have been encouraged to
take on debt by the near zero interest
rates that have prevailed since march of
and as we understood from jerome
powell's speech in jackson hole
that's not going to end any time soon
whenever he decides to end tapering
you do not have a situation where
interest rates are going to rise at all
and i took it from the message that he
gave his interest rate increases are
probably at least one year away from
today
and if that is the case and you're going
to feed all the increase in debt that is
taking place
uh it is something the corporations may
not be able to pay at a higher interest
rate some of them
and you run the risk that the federal
government's debt service payments will
have to increase with an increase in the
10-year bond yield
and that is why the succession in the
federal reserve is critical i have my
own thoughts on what the federal reserve
chairman's term should be
and how he or she
should be nominated but we simply do not
have
the independence of the fed at all in
the current setup and that is a major
concern for me on the debt build up so
what i'm curious because i'm a huge
advocate for term limits in congress and
you've seen with some senators such as
pat toomey that they're able to
legislate much differently knowing that
they're leaving there they take risks
that otherwise they wouldn't take if
they were up for re-election
so what what would you change about term
structure term limits at the fed i'm
curious this is my world
uh it is my world as well so i let me
say i have given it a lot of thought
and
the what i would like is for the fed
chairman
who is presently named for four years
and it happens midway through the
presidential terms so it doesn't end
with the presidential presidential
election but it ends about 15 months
16 months later
i would like that pattern to continue to
provide an element of uh separation
between the president of the country and
the chairman of the federal reserve
but the point i really would like to see
is for the fed chairman to be nominated
for a single six-year term you are not
re-electable
and the reason is today we have all the
speculation about what will happen in
the fed
and powell will be nominated or not
nominated uh starting february 1st 2022
and i had thought that president biden
might announce it by jackson hole but
that's not happening now it's expected
september october
and we see the news report saying
treasury secretary ellen is all in favor
of his renomination so for all practical
purposes it looks like he will be
renominated
what's the problem here he has to be
thinking about that in terms of when to
stop tape i went to stop tapering and to
start that's right increase interest
rates if i would fit chairman put me in
that spot and i would say
i'll take care of it after i'm
renominated exactly let me get past
february the 1st where is fed
independence
absolutely nowhere
so
friend independence is a fiction and the
only way you're going to get out of it
is if you nominate me for six years and
after six years i have to quit and if
that had been done with jerome powell he
has another two more years to go goes
into 2024
and then he knows that he has to be
worried about his legacy how he
performed in six years and then you
would be talking about a successor if
you're thinking about lael brainerd as a
successor for instance she would start
also for another six-year term
or anybody else for that matter
so that i think is a major issue the
second issue i have with the fed
is studying federal reserve history
the last time a federal reserve chairman
was outvoted
was in 1986 the early part of the year
paul walker my hero
in bringing down inflation
found out that he was outvoted and
preston martin the vice chairman
and reagan nominee had voted against him
although by the end of that day he had
pulled his vote back but
first time around
volker was outwarded there was the
mutiny in the echoes mutiny in the fed
and there was a lot of talk doesn't mean
paul volcker should resign i'm not
saying he should have resigned at all
the view then was
president reagan did a few things in
iran contra nicaragua marines get killed
very sad for all of us but he that
doesn't mean that president reagan
should resign he did not resign
in this case i don't think uh chairman
volker should have resigned because of
that
but it is good to have the descent and
have that come out in public oh
absolutely why am i as a taxpayer paying
for 12 voting members but i'm really
getting one person why don't the other
12 11 person why do i need them so
that's the second issue i have with the
way in which the fed is being run you
know when they started taking
transcripts of
federal reserve meetings in 1996
the governor stopped dissenting right
literally we've had three since 1996
mark olson was the last one under under
greenspan i think in 2002
and they've the board has become this
this
i i have hopes i will say it on the
record i have hopes for christopher
waller
because he is the first
board member that i've heard come out
and actively
uh
say that the fed's policies are wrong
right i have a lot of hope i'm very
impressed with christopher waller as
well he has dissented on a few occasions
he has already said that there is need
to be he hasn't dissented yet but i
think he will he will but in talk
actually no i shouldn't use the word
dissent but in his power tv interviews
expressed his disagreements
or concerns about it but here is the
problem the system is such
that even if mr waller were to disagree
it wouldn't mean very much the majority
will still be on the other side with the
chairman that's true but i i think i
mean
as a fed watcher i'm very excited for
2022 just because you've got
one dove two neutrals and one hawk
rotating off of the you've got four
hawks coming in one two three four i i
mean it
in all the years since paul volcker i
don't think you've seen a quintuple
descent and you could be talking about
something of that magnitude given the
change of characters
in january i'm just i'm all i'm excited
right no i hope you are correct i hope
it happens
but it is you need to break through the
system in order to get that situated
that situation because history is not in
favor of it no i know even 1986 by the
end of the day
when president martin had dissented with
paul volcker he pulled the vote
and walker in turn was furiously working
with the governments in west germany
with france and in great britain to make
sure that the german mark
the french franc and the british pound
sterling would not go in a different
direction and they would all reduce the
discount rate or the equivalent rate
together
in order to orchestrate it he could not
act by himself so finally there was no
dissent but but ultimately at least
that's the first indication that you had
that it could happen
and if you have that as you said with so
many hawks
going into 2022 that would be a positive
the question is even before 2008
danielle
you had people who were interviewed
after the crisis
blew up
and they were said why didn't you do and
the answer often was i could not
disagree with chairman bernanke so
openly then why do i pay you a salary oh
absolutely you're not going to disagree
with him and express your intelligent
views in the process i i think there's
very few very little appreciation that
there there is a different structure of
federal reserve district and there there
there is a private ownership
aspect of of the district banks but
the members of the board they're full
government employees right exactly paid
by u.s taxpayers
and they have an object there's this mit
mafia that kind of forms policy within
the board and everybody just seems to go
along so again uh you know i i
there there's my knock on wood for
christopher waller but i i do hope we
start to see
because i think you agree with me uh
i think that that the problem in housing
in the united states has become
extraordinary extraordinarily
problematic and that much of it lies
with with what's happening at the
federal reserve and i don't think it's
going to be transitory i i agree with
you fully i don't think the inflation is
transitory at all
on the housing side let's look at the
inconsistency of policy particularly
with respect to housing
secretary ellen goes in public and she
makes a statement she's very concerned
about house prices increasing especially
because low and middle income first time
buyers cannot afford to buy their first
home
at the same time the federal reserve is
spending 40 billion dollars every month
to buy mortgage-backed securities
essentially pushing the yield down and
making the mortgages cheaper and if you
already own a house your house price is
appreciating and if i don't have a house
and i'm coming to buy it for the first
time
i am left high and dry there's no way i
can compete with you no and plus there's
an army of investors who are taking
advantage of the zero interest rate
policy and coming in with cash even
though it's levered up to the hilt
on wall street but they're coming in
with cash and pricing out these
first-time buyers as well exactly and
look at the here is the other issue
which is more i think statistical
measurement oriented
uh
house prices don't go in the consumer
price index now warner equivalent rent
and rent does owner equivalent rent is
25 of the cpi
owner equivalent rent plus rents which
you pay as a rent uh slse
together it's about one-third of the
total weight so it's significant
but then you have had
massive explosion 16 annual increase in
the home prices
and then it doesn't reflect on the cpi
similar increases in rents right
so
exactly
now though i think that's going to
change and that is i think a new warning
for the fed again on the housing side
that you mentioned what is this
i have been expecting the supreme court
to turn down the biden extension of the
eviction ban
i think he did that in early august
and the president was able to get maybe
20 days out of it and the supreme court
last night said it cannot be done right
so what does it mean
the landlord is going to be able to
evict the tenant
and once the eviction is done the rent
is going to go at a much higher pace for
the new person who's coming in because
the landlord can check your background
your ability to make your rent payment
and it's going to be higher
so i have said
i put out a tweet earlier today saying
later in this year expect
the rent to show up more and more in the
in the consumer price index
what will the chairman power do you'll
probably say it's transitory
if you keep repeating that without but
he knows that that's not transitory
supply chain disruptions even if they go
on for several years starting with the
trade war but supply chain disruptions
you can make the argument that they will
eventually be resolved and the
containers will get into the right ports
and that manufacturers will will will
increase production and supply and
demand curves will cross blah blah blah
blah blah
that's a lease is 12 months
a home price is is a long term purchase
so i don't think i think he would lose
and if you noted with the jackson hole
speech there was not a word he spoke
about housing not one word yeah i
noticed that too very good point
and you know why it's a weak point why
would i bring up as chairman of the
federal reserve housing when he doesn't
support my argument
because he can say they are all supply
bottlenecks but he doesn't say anything
about it
delta variant is useful to his case
that's a new one and therefore we have
to keep inflating the money supply but
the housing goes against it so you don't
talk about it
rents are going to increase so they are
going to push up in that's not
transitory but you don't talk about it
so if you ignore housing and rent you
actually have a freer pass in terms of
saying things will be okay
this is this is the issue
and i in fact i replayed a few days ago
an old woody allen movie
and where he's walking on the street
and there is a car backing up and coming
here to park
and so he stands he's just a person a
pedestrian and the car driver is coming
keep coming keep coming keep coming and
the car comes and then it hits this car
behind it and he said
that's okay and then he walks off
the fed is never wrong
whenever things happen it is somebody
else's fault right uh bernanke and his
fed did not foresee the 2008 crisis they
are considered heroes for what they did
after
but you wouldn't have had to do any risk
rescue if you had anticipated it a lot
of people
were thinking about how much of a
problem it was
and well here we are in the 12th
district where new century and
country-wide mortgage and all kinds of
very obvious
evidence that there was a subprime
bubble and it's right in janet yellen's
backyard and she's treasury secretary
today i can't wrap my head around this
precisely that's an excellent view i
completely subscribe to that
go back to 2008 since we were talking
about it
jackson hole 2005
raghuram rajan who was a chief economist
for the imf at that time
nobody has briefed him on this is going
to be like
for alan greenspan before he leaves the
job
so he honestly talks in terms of it i
have read the speech several times i i
have as well very modest it makes me
say here is somebody that just follow
what happened
and again
a very famous economist sitting in the
audience whom we all know who it is said
this is
he's a financial ladder he doesn't
understand
technology
and so he turned out to be correct and
it almost came word to word in terms of
how what he anticipated except nobody
can predict the time he's speaking in
august 2005
the thing started to fall apart in 2007
and essentially collapsed by september
that's fine you you can't predict it but
i'm saying the fed did not take any
responsibility for it look again at the
fed today
you have
people when they are talking about the
succession powell is very uh again i
liked it in congress his congressional
support is very good in addition to
support from janet yellen he practically
lives on the hill he's had so many
meetings yeah a very political
politically savvy player exactly
and people say why is what do you like
about it he comes here often and he
makes speeches to us that has nothing to
do with monetary policy how impressive
you are to talk to and how nice you are
when you make a presentation so what are
they talking about
they it has become very clear and again
this goes to the crux of why the fed is
not independent the only candidate who
was talked about as a possible
replacement for powell is lyle brainer
in the in recent weeks
not very strongly but at least anybody
mentioned yep
but what do they say that both of them
agree on continuing the quantitative
easing both of them agree on bond
purchases because it's very popular with
congress too
where does she differ from chairman
powell in terms of regulation
some people in congress thinks he's too
light on regulation she wants more
regulation i think i would prefer her
because i like regulation or i prefer
him because i like quantitative easing
but she dare not go
and speak against the bond purchase if
she has a chance of continuing and now
it's mentioned she'll become the vice
chairman in the new setup and so all of
that big nature she gets the head of
regulation warren is placated
senator elizabeth warren is placated
everybody's happy everybody is happy
except the economy will pay a price
right and whether it will be in six
months over the next two years that's
what is not clear
no i think you're right um but i i will
have to say and i'd love for your you
know the the the fastest
uh recession that we had prior to this
was in i think 1980 and it was six
months right in duration and this one
was
two months which isn't even technically
a reset it really feels like we had a
bump along the way and then you have
43.2 percent of gdp injected into the
economy with fiscal
stimulus as well as what the federal
reserve is doing do you think there's a
chance that that the
the compre the time has been compressed
in a post-pandemic world especially if
there's nothing coming
on the fiscal side and i mean when i say
the fiscal side i mean checks in people
people's pockets
um
first of all in terms of the definition
of a recession by the national bureau of
economic research which is the final
arbiter of the date when it began and
the date when the recession ended
um even though we use two quarters of
negative gdp that's not really the
definition it is a
comprehensive downward movement of
various sectors within the economy so
when you take that into account um last
year probably qualifies as a recession
because it was not too long as you said
but at least it was comprehensive
everybody went down and i was looking
at the net
the nfp the job creation number we lost
about 20 million jobs in a single month
february of 2020. yes so in that sense
it qualifies
as being a recession
your question was is the time lip time
produced i think this was reduced
because they just threw everything
including the kitten into the
kitchen sink so to say
the monetary policy fiscal policy in
numbers which were which make the
2008-2009 rescue look like child play
compared with what we did
therefore
we came out of it very very fast and i
have a basic principle if you now that
both of us are in santa monica
if you go and you take hundred thousand
dollars worth of 100 bills
right outside in the small area and you
distribute it from a helicopter and let
it fall
the gdp of santa monica would have
increased immediately by hundred
thousand dollars yes by definition of
course that is the statistics
and as people pick up the hundred dollar
bills and they spend it there will be
more multiplied effect
that doesn't mean santa monica will
generate more employment for the next
five years
that is what has happened with the
fiscal and monetary stimulus you have
done something to get you out of the rut
immediately
and i have been a big fan of structural
reforms
i watched germany in 2003 2005 with
chancellor gerhard schroeder
and then allowing the fact that you as a
worker who do not have skills which are
in demand
if you would take a cut in your pay
the government will subsidize your
education to become a welder or a
carpenter for which there is there is
demand right
the welder or carpenter the person who
runs the firm wants to hire you because
you're cheap the government is
subsidizing
a year passes by when you're an
apprentice now you're skilled
the employer doesn't want to let go of
you
and that's what happened in bringing the
german unemployment rate down
not because they ran a huge fiscal
deficit or the german there was no
bundesbank by then you had the european
central bank which was uh providing all
the cash in order to do that
but they empowered they re-empowered
they reskilled their workforce exactly
and we've done apps we've done the
opposite we've encouraged people to stay
out of the workforce and now they have
serious skills atrophy
and we're saying
and there's concern going forward that
we're not going to have the right
workers for the right positions
this has been 19 months of a wasted
opportunity absolutely correct that is
that is to me
is the big issue if you look at the 1.9
trillion and the in the biden stimulus
plan
or even if you look more at the 3.5 or
3.7 trillion more that the house passed
you are looking at very little that is
talked about in terms of worker training
and any established means of growing
your skill productivity
instead it's a case of let's pour more
cash into it and that will create growth
but it will not sustain it no that's
just that's that that is the traditional
definition of pork right so to speak um
and and and you do so this this is why
i'm
curious and i'm i'm looking at the 1980
episode of this very quick recession and
then we went back
into recession that ended up being a
double-dip recession right
and again we're looking at the potential
for a parallel because there hasn't we
haven't
done anything productive
in the aftermath of this two-month
crash in economic output productivity
workers lost uh so i i i don't know what
is going to be a lot most of the sell
side economists seem to think that the
economy is just going to continue
propelling itself along
but very few can explain how
right this is going to happen
i think you're spot on here is the issue
you have recovered the recession of 2020
was a short one we have recovered
but inflation in my mind is going to be
sustained and stay high
and if that happens to be the case and
people say to me why am i talking about
stagflation it happened in 1979
because the oil was a very essential
commodity there was no substitute for it
and it went up so much in price
my answer is you have so many
commodities now in short supply not one
but several
and pouring cash is not going to make
those commodities increase in the amount
that are available to you
so the chances for a stagflation is if
you look at it in a keynesian sense
it's aggregate demand and how much
you're boosting
and all of the unemployment compensation
and paying people to stay unemployed
means that they have adequate amount of
money in terms of personal consumption
today's consumption numbers showed
a very healthy increase it is continuing
to take place
and i think on top of that you have all
the government spending that is taking
place that will keep the growth high for
some time
but then inflation is not going to come
down in a meaningful manner at some
point in time
the
investors will take notice
and again chairman powell saying that
inflation is transitory may make less
and less sense
again i come back to my favorite theme
of fed independence
if he has been nominated by september
and then he goes it's probably less of a
consequence personally thereafter and
that's the cost that we'll all have to
pay that's right
and there's also the other elephant in
the room and and most people
discount it but i i think that we should
be
at least cognizant of the 2011 episode
with the debt ceiling and
how very far
politicians were willing to push the
finances of the country
in the name of of trying to ensure that
they got their political pound of flesh
and we have these midterms coming up and
and the country is running
low on money pretty quickly we're
burning through money quicker than we
expect it to because of what's going on
in afghanistan as well so
and again we have janet yellen running
the treasury department so i i think
that that cannot also be discounted
because the federal reserve will never
get in the
in the middle of a political battlefield
they will always step back
from from something like that so that
could even push your policy error
further even further you are right i
there's absolutely there's nothing i can
disagree on that point right now you
have the
extension of ec policy due to the fed
renomination
going into 2022 you're talking about
then you're already in an election year
i'm staying away from afghanistan
because so far
the impact is not clear but however
if the conflict increases and the
defense spending has to increase for the
united states which we have not factored
in we are only talking about fiscal
stimulus for the unemployed and so on
then you are going to add more to
spending and more uh borrowing that is
going to take place
all of that
this was something i feared and for four
years i had been a dove on the 10-year
yield
and going against consensus in saying
10-year yield is going to go down and
oftentimes this is from
2017 2018 through into early 2021
i abruptly changed on january 5th
with the two georgia senate elections
right went over to the democrats now
they have all branches of government
and what what has happened since makes
me very frightened i haven't changed my
view i now think
that interest rates are due to increase
and if you add on top of a defense
expenditure related to afghanistan
you're going to put even more pressure
on the treasury yield
than has happened so far
well we are definitely at a a very
tenuous
juncture
with with that in mind
where do you feel the dollar
is going to be in 10 or 20 years
uh i'll give you an answer i'll answer
your question and also give you an
answer over two years and then 20 years
over two years there is no substitute
for the dollar it's not the chinese
renminbi
there are still a lot of foreign
exchange and capital controls the
chinese have
and so it's not fully freely tradable so
that's not going to happen
and the euro is not going to take its
place as easily either
japanese yen i think is in decline so
you can't
go there to get a break
so the dollar is no competition
and that's why i think the dxy the
dollar index after being at 90 91 in the
last few weeks
has gone up to 93
because they are saying the fed at least
is thinking of tapering
and the ecb is the european central bank
is not the bank of japan is definitely
not going to do anything like that
so the dollar remains strong and there
is no alternative to the dollar so it's
going to hang around on the dxy side
between say 91 and 95 range
for the next couple of years
over the next 20 years
i go to europe often that is at least
pre covered used to visit regularly
and i am impressed
with their coming together to form a 750
billion euro common euro
bond which would be the obligation
i wrote a piece saying
that this is the equivalent of an
alexander hamiltonian movement for the
united states when in 1789
he had 13 colonies 13 states to deal
with you had profligate massachusetts
and you had conservative virginia
and you had to make both of them agree
to have even massachusetts debt be taken
on by all 13 states rather than by one
state and he succeeded and that was the
beginning of the federal debt issuance
i never thought the europeans would do
it in my lifetime
bob mundell used to talk about european
integration and what was happening there
this is taking place
with these uh
the issuance of the 750 billion euro
bond not only that
just like at that in 1789 you had to
give more money to massachusetts and
virginia was the contributor
now
germany netherlands austria are the
creditor countries or the contributors
the entity benefiting the most are going
to be italy in spain italy is going to
get about
192 billion euros out of the 750.
so the others are agreeing to it
why am i saying all this
if that is a further step in european
integration
and as a result of the cobit situation
and i'm impressed with what mario draghi
has been able to achieve in italy
if he is able to get structural reforms
passed in italy and therefore that
forces even spain and greece
to make the changes
especially on the labor side because the
labor market is completely inflexible in
very many of these countries you can't
be fired and if you are in your
mid to late 50s you are well settled in
your job
that you're not you can't be replaced
which means the youth unemployment is
very high because unless you leave they
can't get your job right
that is in the process of changing they
are allowing more people to be hired on
a contract basis
so put together the integration that is
coming on the monetary side
and on top of it structural reforms and
the likelihood and you asked me to look
at 20 years ahead i am
20 years ahead let's say that europe is
a much more integrated place and you
also have more of these structural
reforms being implemented
then you can have europe become a
credible competitor to the dollar
or the chinese may open up their
currency and they can do that
in a sense if those would be
disciplining devices for the federal
reserve and for the treasury you can't
get away with doing what you're doing
right now
you know you've opened my eyes to the
the potential for europe because people
always talk about that as as being an
impossibility to bring the italians and
the spen the spaniards in the front but
they're certainly an economic motive
certainly an economic motive um before
we uh before we end this i'm uh i i need
to congratulate you you've got a
granddaughter oh thank you thank you
very much
we are very happy the family situation
is great and i'm leaving soon to go see
my granddaughter yet again well good um
let's pick up this conversation again
hopefully we can do it in new york next
time that would be fun wonderful bring
that city back to life excellent i look
forward to it i really enjoyed your
conversation your questions i think were
right on the mark very timely and i
appreciate being a part of it thank you
for being here thank you
well i hope you're as enlightened as i
am
uh in the event that uh that you enjoyed
this discussion i certainly did sri is a
beautiful thinker uh be sure and go back
and catch uh an earlier down the middle
episode with leland miller of the beige
of the china beige book and he could add
a little bit to the china side of the
analysis
and uh and if you haven't please do
subscribe
i look forward to the next time of down
the middle with dimartino booth thank
you
[Music]